[Musique]
bonjour l'actualité européenne et bien
nous tentons de vous la faire vivre
malgré le confinement et oui votre
émission europe et de haut elle s'adapte
et tout de suite et bien on retrouve
jean claude trichet ancien président de
la bce la banque centrale européenne de
2003 à 2011
bonjour tout d'abord comment se passe
votre confinement où êtes vous écoutez
je suis chez moi j'ai la chance d'avoir
un appartement qui est assez lumineux
donc de ce point de vue là je suis
légier et je ne sais bien et ma foi je
travaille je j'ai beaucoup de relations
par internet et par vidéo et comment
passe comment occupez-vous un petit peu
plus précisément vos journées on vous
avait envoyé des photos doit de
confinement on va vous lisez notamment
julien gracq ce que vous lisez beaucoup
plus que d'habitude
d oui bien sûr plus que d'habitude de ce
que parce que j'étais beaucoup plus de
temps quand même que d'habitude et en
effet julie mais je dois dire que en sus
comme il y a énormément de possibilités
internet
je continue à travailler à peu près
comme avant et il se trouve que j'ai
quelques responsabilités internationales
donc je suis assez sûr aux liaisons que
je le disais à vous étiez à la tête de
la bce a durant la crise bancaire et
financière en 2008 est ce que la crise
de 2008 elle est comparable à celle que
nous vivons aujourd'hui
il ya des similitudes ne serait ce que
parce qu'on a à la fois en effet une
crise maintenant crise financière est
une crise économique de l'économie
réelle mais il y a énormément de
différences 1
nous avons une crise qui est d'emblée
mondial parce qu'une pandémie c'est une
crise mondiale alors que en 2008 on
avait une crise qui naissaient dans les
grands pays a lancé
deuxièmement on a une grille monnaie ni
de l'économie réelle comme on dit ni de
l'économie financière noté tanks mais
qui naît d'une crise sanitaire
et ça c'est une originalité considérable
c'est la crise sanitaire qui provoque
finalement les deux crises parallèle
économique et financier puis il se
trouve que cette ce détonateur sanitaire
intervient dans un environnement à la
fois au sein des pays avancés mais sur
le plan mondial qui est un environnement
qui était déjà fragile parce que on a
plu aux états et une croissance depuis
très longtemps et donc on savait qu'une
récession était possible aux états unis
de même il y avait eu manifestement des
bulles financières qui s'étaient créés
donc vous voyez la crise sanitaire
intervient dans un univers qui étaient
déjà fragilisées
jean claude trichet quel regard portez
vous sur l'action de la banque centrale
européenne aujourd'hui 1 face à cette
crise inédite vous venez de le dire je
précise l'institution a présenté par la
française christine lagarde a annoncé un
programme de rachat d'actifs un de 750
milliards d'euros
est ce que c'est une bonne chose est ce
suffisant c'est une bonne chose qui
était absolument nécessaire dont des
toiles mans de cette crise très grave ce
n'est pas la seule décision européenne
centrale européenne a aussi pris la
décision de donner de la liquidité sans
aucune limite à toute l'économie
européenne
et ceci est évidemment très important
elle a aussi décidé de faire en sorte
que les banques puissent mettre à la
disposition des entreprises européennes
des crédits de manière extrêmement
abondant et elle a alors un agent de nos
jardins
vous allez me le pardonner ce sont les
refinancement à long terme ciblés
ciblées pour permettre précisément aux
banques de prêter aux entreprises et là
l album centrale européenne a décidé de
les porter à un niveau absolument
considérable qui peut aller jusqu'à 1000
milliards d'euros supplémentaires dont
on est réellement en présence des forces
considérables
ceci dit les banques centrales ne
peuvent pas tout faire la banque
centrale européenne fait beaucoup la
federal reserve fait beaucoup et la
banque du japon c'est beaucoup mais les
gouvernements et l'état ont évidemment
eu même prendre leurs responsabilités
alors justement le président de la
république 1 s'est exprimé il ya
quelques jours aux français elle a
notamment abordé le rôle que devait
jouer les banques et les assurances pour
affronter la crise
je vous propose de l'écouter petit temps
les commerçants les professions
libérales et les entrepreneurs
le fonds de solidarité apporte une
première réponse mais je sais votre
angoisse je les ai entendus je les lui
les charges qui continuent de tomber les
traite les loyers les emprunts c'est
pourquoi j'ai demandé au gouvernement
d'accroître fortement les aides de les
simplifier pour vous permettre de
surmonter cette période
je souhaite que les banques puissent
décalé toutes les échéances beaucoup
plus massivement qu'elles ne l'ont fait
et les assurances doivent être au
rendez-vous de cette mobilisation
économique jean-claude trichet les
banques sont elles en mesure sont elles
suffisamment en bonne santé pour pouvoir
décaler toutes les échéances et de
manière massive est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec les propos des malades
macron l'époque ont des efforts à faire
heureusement ils sont bien meilleures
situations odile une bien meilleure
situation qu'elle ne l'était en 2007
2008 dans la crise précédente
ceci dit bien entendu on s'attend à ce
que tous les partenaires fassent des
efforts dans les circonstances présentes
aussi bien les banques que les
assurances donc on s'attend à ce que
l'on chine tire la charrue dans le même
souci
alors justement dans son discours le
président français a également parlé
d'europe qui devaient être ambitieuse il
ya une semaine l'eurogroupe qui réunit
les
ministre des finances de la zone euro
est parvenue à un consensus avant de
rentrer dans les détails de l'accord
écoutez donc son président mario sans
piano
chaque jour on nous rappelle que ce
virus est aveugle aveugle à nos drapeaux
au sexe à la couleur ou à la classe
sociale
il n'y a pas de passagers en première
classe nous coulons où nous nageons
ensemble
il s'agit d'une véritable urgence c'est
une urgence mondiale concernant les
enjeux pour l'europe vous pouvez cac et
c'est j'imagine avec les propos du
président l'eurogroupe nous coulons où
nous nageons ensemble
oui c'est c'est le cas chaque fois que
nous avons une crise
en l'occurrence d'ailleurs une crise
mondiale donc aussi une crise
continental on a les mêmes problèmes
justement dans l'ensemble lui avancé et
demain parce que c'est pas encore très
visibles on aura les mêmes problèmes
dans les pays en développement les pays
les plus pauvres
mais si je reprends le cas de l'europe
les efforts qui sont faits par la banque
centrale européenne on en a déjà à
risques sont considérables et ils sont à
mon avis à la hauteur des défis pour les
états
c'est sont également des sommes énormes
monde ont pas parce que il faut faire
l'addition de ce qui est fait au niveau
national et de ce qu'il fait au niveau
européen alors justement les pays de
l'eurogroupe sont parvenus non sans mal
à un accord portant sur 500 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires soit plus de 4%
du pib de la zone euro avec plusieurs
outils 1 pour atténuer l'impact
notamment un soutien aux états membres
via le mécanisme de stabilité européen
un accord suffisamment ambitieux à la
hauteur là aussi il ya la coopé donc les
540 millions de milliards d'euros qui
ont été décidées et qui vont dans le bon
sens évidemment mais ils viennent en sus
d'énormes efforts faits par les états
eux mêmes ou additionnel quand
j'additionne le tout j'arrive tenez vous
bien rester assise à 3 nil bleu 100
milliards dhs
c'est à dire des sommes qui sont non
seulement au niveau nous espérons les
américains mais même un peu supérieur à
ce que fo delà au delà où il faut avoir
certaines femmes arcade vision globale
et selon parlait le président du jour
s'est en effet quelque chose de
considérable avec trois volets un volet
de prêt du mécanisme européen le stade
deux cent quarante mille milliards
d'euros un volet de la banque européenne
d'investissement de 100 milliards
d'euros et un volet de la leçon
milliards et une démesure exclu pour le
moment pas par l'eurogroupe qui apporte
en la faveur de plusieurs états membres
ce sont les corona bon soit l'émission
de dette commune
est-ce qu'il faut sérieusement que
l'union européenne envisage cette
réponse c'est un sujet qui revient de
manière récurrente et consiste à dire
sommes pas encore une fédération
politique ne sommes pas encore une
fédération budgétaire et nous sommes
suffisamment proche d'une fédération
pour pouvoir commencer à émettre des
obligations des trésors européens de
manière conjointe dans le jargon
juridique on dirait de manière conjointe
et solidaire c'est à dire que tout le
monde serait responsable de l'émission
aussi bien les pays qui ont une très
bonne signature si je puis dire que les
pays qui ont une moins bonne signature
ce serait ça le l'idée de manoeuvre
alors on a pas de décision en effet
parce qu'il n'y a pas de consensus sur
ce point mais en revanche il a été
décidé d'étudier la question
donc monsieur trichet pour pouvoir
répondre plus rapidement et plus
efficacement est ce qu'il est nécessaire
de construire de bâtir une union plus
politique ce panneau mobile dont je
crois qu'effectivement nous sommes en
présence d'un processus historique de
très très ambitieux et de long terme qui
a commencé donc il ya 70 ans ou plus et
qui va se poursuivre et donc je pense
qu'on est fait il y a beaucoup de choses
à compléter dans la construction elle
même style nous n'allons pas être
l'équivalent des états unis d'amérique
parce que la france n'est pas la
californie et l'allemagne faisaient pas
la floride
donc nous à nous inventons quelque chose
au niveau européen je crois que nous
devons progresser dans beaucoup de
dimension nous devons progresser en
donnant encore plus de responsabilités
au parlement européen pour avoir un
teint responsabilités et légitimité
démocratique supérieure à celle que nous
avons actuellement il faut donner plus
de responsabilités et plus de pouvoir
amener les aux institutions européennes
et maire parce que on a besoin en effet
de réaction qui soit plus rapide et plus
important merci jean claude trichet nous
avoir accordé cet entretien et
maintenant direction manage
[Musique]
et chaque semaine pour conclure cette
émission nous nous rendrons dans un pays
de l'union européenne à la rencontre
d'un citoyen européen confiné cette
semaine c'est vous myriam française vous
habitez à mal et depuis 2018 vous êtes
ont filé avec votre mari votre fille de
deux ans et demi un confinement beaucoup
plus stricte qu'en france même s'il a
les activités reprennent peu à peu
raconté non oui effectivement mais ça
fait déjà depuis un peu plus d'un mois
qu'on est tous confinés de façon assez
strictes et je pense qu'on a bien bien
respecté un toute la population
espagnole s'est mise en marche
finalement assez rapidement là il fait
la semaine de la semaine sainte en fait
la semaine passée à madrid tout le monde
a été dans une obligation de cesser
toutes les activités ça a été totalement
fermé cette semaine on voit on voit on
voit les photos que vous allez envoyer
un des rues complètement désert verte
effectivement c'est vraiment à
l'encontre en fait de l'adn delà de la
société espagnole qui ne se s'étaient
qui vivent en dehors qui vit un intense
vie sociale et bon finalement à tout le
monde s'est plié à l'exercice tout
simplement pour le bon sens pour la
nécessité de de faire face à cette
pandémie
resmed activités reprennent un tout
petit peu quand même la wii alors
lui-même effectivement ils ont autorisé
au niveau gouvernemental la reprise des
activités de construction par exemple
enfin tout ce qui était activités dites
industries non essentiels toutes les
activités qui avaient été suspendues par
principe de précaution ont pu reprendre
par contre effectivement il ya un
certain nombre d'activités très critique
au niveau espagnol qui restent fermés
comme comme l'hôtellerie et la
restauration alors justement le tourisme
vous vous êtes peut-être une catastrophe
économique pour un pays comme l'espagne
qui vous touchent personnellement à
travers votre mari racontez nous oui en
effet conjoint travaille dans
l'hôtellerie la propriétaire d'un
nouveau stade à peine investi c'est un
petit hôtel et donc du jour au lendemain
l'activité est passé de 200 à 0 les
revenus sont à zéro il n'y a aucune
perspective pour le moment concrète une
date précise de reprise l'activité dans
ce secteur qui fait vivre vraiment
l'espagne puisque celle ci c'est le
moteur en fait 1 du pib c'est le moteur
de l'emploi énormément de
de soucis et préoccupations par rapport
à cette perspective parce qu'on ne sait
pas où ni comment ça va reprendre ni
quand vont ouvrir les frontières ni dans
quelles conditions les l'activité va
pouvoir être reprise et les aides
évidemment au niveau espagnols ont été
pensés mais elle tarde à arriver
donc c'est une situation extrêmement
critique pour tous secteurs avec
beaucoup d'incertitudes merci myriam on
termine cette émission avec vous prenez
soin de vous à madrid et puis donner une
longue liste de vos nouvelles alors voir
ou à revoir
[Musique]
i